على مقربه من بكين ترمي دول مجموعه السبع
حبال الوصل طاره وتشدها طاره كما تقول دول
المجتمعه في هيروشيما اليابانيه تريد بناء
علاقات مستقره مع الصين لكنها تعارض السعي
الصيني لعسكره اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
كانت استبقت البياض الختاميه للمجموعه
بوعيد على لسان السفاراتها في لندن
لاجراءات قويه وحازمه ليس فقط ازاء
الافعال وانما الاقوال ايضا
البيان الختامي لدول السبع اكد على ضروره
حل المشاكل الاقليميه السلميه واحترام
السياده الدول كما اكد على موقف المجموعه
من مبدا الصين واحده موقف مصحوب برفض
للمحاولات الاحاديه لتغيير الوضع القائم
بالقوه والاكراه اضافه الى رفض مطالب بكين
التوسعي في بحر الصين الجنوبي
بينما يريد قاده المجموعه التمكين
للعلاقات الاقتصاديه مع الصين
سيواجهون سياساتها غير القائمه على السوق
اضافه لمواجهه ممارسه الصين على غرار
النقل غير المشروع للتكنولوجيا وتعزيز
القدرات على مواجهه الاكراه الاقتصادي
يريد قاده مجموعه السبع من الصين الضغط
على روسيا لوقف حملتها العسكريه في
اوكرانيا وسحب قواتها بشكل فوري وشامل
وبدون شروط من اوكرانيا وفقا لميثاق الامم
المتحده ومن خلال حوار مباشر مع اوكرانيا
وبين شد وجذب وتقرب وانتقاد تقول بكين
انما يقال ويعمل عليه افتراء وتشويه سمعه
والرد سيكون حاضر لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات